the coronavirus has forced hospitals
across
the country to ban visitors that has
created a terrible situation
for some parents who have not been
allowed to see their sick children
face to face but families in one
community outside new york city are
reuniting with their kids
after a children's hospital lifted its
month-long visiting restrictions
we spoke with one mother who says she
feels like a piece of her
has finally returned
for the first time in nearly five months
catherine rivera was able to hold her
daughter maria
in her arms
back in march the long-term care unit at
the blydsdale children's hospital
stopped allowing all visitors
including parents to protect
immuno-compromised patients like maria
she looks so big she's grown it's
a big relief really really big relief
the four and a half-year-old has spent
nearly her entire life
in the hospital before she was born she
was diagnosed with a rare joint disease
a condition with no cure she's been a
fighter i mean she's
beat all the other odds doctors didn't
have much hope but
she proved them wrong
[Music]
it's been too long since the hospital
lifted its visiting restrictions last
week
there have been more than a dozen
emotional reunions between children
and their families some like katherine
cope with the distance
through regular video calls it wasn't
the same as you know
hugging her and carrying her there was
days where it was really hard on me
but what got rivera through 145 days of
not being able to touch maria
was knowing her daughter was in good
hands we don't call them nurses or
doctors we call them our aunts and
uncles
they are family to us they're amazing i
wasn't worried about
her missing me because she has enough
love here
jeff and enrique this story broke my
heart it was so bittersweet on one hand
it's so great that the parents are
finally able to see their children on
the other
this virus is infecting all aspects of
our lives
it's nice to see the parents reunited
after that long